- We were just talking about
being stuck in a bucket.
Have you ever been stuck
like that in anything?
- Not in a bucket.
This past year, I was hosting
the NAACP Image Awards
and literally five minutes
before the live show,
me and my entire family and security
were stuck in the elevator.
- Okay, I was going to
say it was an elevator.
I've been stuck in an elevator.
- Yeah, stuck in the elevator
and it took three and a
half minutes to get us out.
- [Kelly] Oh!
So we had a minute and a half
before the show went live.
And once I got out, the
elevator dropped back down
to the basement.
So then I had to run up the stairs.
And as I ran up the stairs, I
saw the producers talking to,
I hope I pronounce her name
correctly, Leticia Right,
from, uh, um, um.
- [Kelly] This is like
me every day right now.
- Oh Covid, damn you Covid.
(Kelly laughing)
- Damn you Covid test diggin'
in my nose to my brain.
(Kelly laughing)
- Black Panther, oh my God,
she was in Black Panther
and so the producers
were huddled in the corner.
- What a great movie.
- Trying to figure out what
they were going to tell,
how she was going to start the show
if I was still stuck in the elevator.
- Oh my gosh, that is a
different level of panic.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm not down for that.